[موسيقى]
العملاق لامبي وناكولا لوموم
شكراً أو أوباما ألدن هنا - لا يوجد مأمور
إعادة تحديد أعلم أن لدي
باسيللا بشكل إجرامي - فكرت هنا حتى أقصد
ملء عيون القط ، إنها رسالة حب
لأطبائنا رسالة حب إلى  ممرضاتنا
وغيرهم من المتخصصين في الرعاية الصحية الذين
يخاطرون بحياتهم من أجل حياتنا
نحتفل بشجاعتك وبطولتك
allomere shuriken Ashura
دقيقتين أنثوية عواء الشب Phil
Heflin Musafir بعد Evita anima كان
فيلم رجل حتى Elena D'Amato
شيري كوتو  مواطن عالمي يو إس إيه
توداي بوكر بيل عبارة عن مادة مخلوق جديدة
تطالب الطمع في أوقات فراغنا
بتقليد أكثر من البالغين ، انظر يا لي
هيرمان إل إيه إم ، تسمية البيانات ثم ستيفي
وندر الذي كان
إلتون جون بول مكارتني مختبئًا في
فاتون  أوبرا إيلام الأوغندية النخبة أليسيا
هنا أندريا بوتشيلي أينما انتهى
[موسيقى]